[Musique]
bonjour valérie ragot
merci le ravissement retrouver en
plateau en plateau
pourtant vrai merci beaucoup d'être là
vous êtes députée de tarn et garonne
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale en ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par patrice moyon
de resf france bonjour patrick bonjour
oriane et on commence par cette
actualité c'est manifestation contre les
violences policières et le racisme dans
la police et ces annonces de christophe
castaner ses premières mesures le
ministre qui prône une tolérance zéro
qui dit notamment qu'il y aura une
suspension systématique pour chaque
soupçons avérés de racisme ce sont ses
mots
l'abandon de certaines méthodes comme la
méthode dite de l'étranglement est ce
que les réponses apportées par
christophe castaner sont les bonnes ce
sont des premières réponses qui sont
satisfaisantes on va pas mentir il l'a
fait dans l'urgence moi ce que je
regrette c'est que pendant six mois il a
fait travailler des élus locaux des
préfectures la gendarmerie la police
pour un livre blanc et ce livre blanc
devait être rendu en janvier 2020 donc
on peut pas dire que c'est à cause du
coc vide 19 de lakovic 19 pardon que ce
livre blanc n'a pas pu être rendu il
devait être rendu avant le déclenchement
de l'épidémie donc ça je le regrette
parce que je suis certaine qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont émergé des
territoires et surtout ça a permis
d'avoir une confrontation de position
entre des élus les préfectures la
gendarmerie les policiers donc tout ça
je ne sais pas ce que c'est devenu alors
il dit que ce sera rendue dans les
prochaines semaines
oui oui d'accord mais enfin il ya un
moment donné c'est quand même bien aussi
d'éviter de faire toujours des choses
dans l'urgence est de pouvoir avoir une
doctrine qui émane de des changes qui
ont lieu sur le terrain qui permettent
vraiment de cadrer les choses dont je
regrette que ce livre blanc est pas été
rendus dans les temps alors que toutes
les réunions se sont tenues elles dans
les temps sur les territoires donc on va
voir ce qui va émerger d'ici trois
semaines mais je pense que ça aurait été
bien le faire avant voilà jacques toubon
défenseur des droits parle d'une crise
de confiance envers la police vous
partager cette analyse jacques toubon il
a vraiment est remontée directe et puis
nous on voit aussi quand même
certain nombre de mouvements qui se met
en place il ya je pense qu'il ya deux
mouvements
on a tous salué la police la gendarmerie
quand il ya eu les attentats faut pas
l'oublier
c'était pas et c'était y'a pas si
longtemps et puis il peut arriver qu
effectivement dans certains cas on est
une vraie rupture de confiance
la république la république doit faire
en sorte que on a besoin d'une police je
pense que tout le monde était pour là
dessus et que cette confiance soir créé
en dépit de kaki qui sont sans doute
avéré évidemment mais qui doivent être
dénoncées par l'institution je pense que
c'est ce message là qu'on attend de
manière très forte
mais quand vous entendez christian jacob
dire qu'il n'ya pas de violences
policières
quand il dit qu'il n'y a pas de police
raciste mais des policiers à six comme
il y en a dans d'autres corps de métier
est ce que vous partagez mais qui est
des cas individuels comme dans toute
population
on est d'accord la seule petite
différence c'est que quand on est la
police la gendarmerie
on incarne la république comme les élus
incarne la république et donc il y à ce
devoir de faire en sorte que quand il ya
des cas qui se produisent ça doit
arriver comme partout mais vous dis là
c'est l'exécution
oui mais il n'y a pas de police reste
mais l'institution l'institution a un
devoir supplémentaire par rapport à ce
qui peut se passer dans l'est de la
société donc c'est ça qui doit être
appelée de manière extrêmement forte par
le gouvernement parle ensemble à mon
avis de la classe politique
et si le gouvernement et si nous
constatons que ce n'est pas le cas alors
il doit y avoir absolument tout de suite
des mesures correctes l'institution
s'est notamment le ministre a pas eu
assez de fermeté de ses vérités jusqu'à
maintenant
ben on l'a jamais trop entendu
jusqu'avant pas avant ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui donc il
faut qu'il y ait un message qui soit
extrêmement fort quand on porte les
cantons incarne les valeurs de la
république
l'institution peut pas se permettre de
dérapage et s'il y en a eh bien elle
doit les sanctionner et le faire savoir
il y à des manifestations qui se
multiplient dans plusieurs villes de
france contre ces violences policières
contre le racisme dans la police est-ce
que sur la forme vous dit que c'est une
bonne chose ces manifestations est ce
que par exemple la manifestation de ce
soir qui aura lieu à paris le parti
socialiste sera présent oui parti
socialiste sera présent
malgré le contexte sanitaire actuelle
qui interdit les rassemblements
qui interdit les rassemblements ne pose
pas de problème sur la forme dans le
contexte sanitaire actuelle ces
manifestations il ya un mouvement
mondial il ya une réflexion donc le
parti socialiste y sera mais en
parallèle de sa nous défendons
l'institution que représente à la fois
la police et la gendarmerie nous disons
juste que on sait bien que dans toute
société il peut y avoir des cas de
dérapage encore une fois j'insiste là
dessus c'est à l'institution de porter
cette parole forte parce qu'elle
représente énormément et moi je le redis
je n'oublie pas le voile à l'héroïsme
des policiers lors des attentats et des
gendarmes
donc voyez au sein d'une même
institution vous pouvez avoir ces deux
balances mais je pense que cet héroïsme
où c'est en tout cas cette force qui
existe que nous avons vu dans les
attentats c'est vraiment celle qui doit
incarner l'institution on va parler d'un
autre sujet patrice on va passer aux
déconfinement oui alors est-ce que sur
sur cette d'abord le déconfinement
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que la france a le bon
tempo aujourd'hui par rapport aux autres
pays européens
on voit que la reprise économique par
exemple les plus rapides en allemagne
oui alors la reprise économique est plus
rapide en allemagne
c'est une question que j'ai posée la
semaine dernière au premier ministre en
lui disant quand vous annoncez une chute
de notre valeur ajoutée en 2020 de 11%
ce qui fait quand même quand on
réfléchit à ce que ça veut dire 250
milliards d'euros de moins de création
de valeur ajoutée en 2020 par rapport à
2019 ce qui est monstrueux vous vous moi
on n'a jamais connu ça jamais jamais
jamais donc on sait pas à ce que ça le
choc que l'économie doit encaisser ça
signifie aussi si on fait en termes de
tempo comme vous dites que l'activité
économique ne retrouvera pas son niveau
d'avant crise avant janvier 2021
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est
très très long qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire
on s'aperçoit que la commission
européenne a publié des statistiques
jeudi dernier en disant qu'elle est le
pays parmi les 27 de l'union européenne
où le commerce de détail a le plus chuté
c'est la france - 30 % moins 30% de
commerce de détail
et notre machine économique en france
c'est pas le cas de tous les pays mais
c'est pas le cas de l'allemagne
notamment
mais de la france fonctionne à 60% sur
la consommation c'est à dire que on crée
de la valeur avec de la consommation
pour 60% de notre économie
donc ça s'est enrayée c'est sur ce point
là que le gouvernement devrait
absolument mettre un plan de relance
avec un soutien à la consommation
nous nous l'avions dit il ya déjà deux
mois avec le soutien aux familles 250
300 euros par famille plus 100 euros par
enfant
nous l'avions dit en faisant en sorte
que d'avoir des chèques vacances un peu
plus solides que ceux qui ont été
proposés fin des chèques pour les
vacances donc ça c'étaient des mesures
très concrètes qui permettait cette
relance entre autres via le biais de la
consommation
pour l'instant le gouvernement n'a pas
répondu sur ces points-là le sénateur
philippe dominati qui était à votre
place à il ya quelques minutes nous
disait qu'il était favorable à une
baisse de la tva comme ça se fait en
allemagne une baisse temporaire en
allemagne est ce que vous êtes
favorables vont essayer mais moi je suis
surtout favorable
la baisse de la tva c'est pas toujours
ce qui relance la consommation parce que
la marche peut être conservé par la
personne qui vous vend le produit donc
forcément ça pas trop de mais en tout
cas c'est pas la bonne solution
ce qui est sûr c'est que on voit qu'il
ya des c'est la question c'est que j'ai
posé le premier ministre la semaine
dernière qui a complètement stoppé sa
consommation
et s'il ya véritablement des preuves des
problèmes de revenus pour cette personne
là c'est ça qu'il faut soutenir et on le
sait en voit sur tous nos territoires et
b qui a des personnes qui ont arrêté de
consommer parce qu'elles n'ont plus
d'argent
on en parlait en de ces chiffres et de
ces mesures que prend le gouvernement il
ya un troisième budget rectificatif qui
sera présenté demain en conseil des
ministres notamment pour relancer les
secteurs en difficulté alors on n'a pas
le détail
non plus est-ce que néanmoins ces
budgets rectificatifs ces mesures qui
ont été prises par le gouvernement
durant cette crise au niveau de
l'économie avant dans le bon sens nous
on a voté les deux premier budget
d'urgence
le plfr 1 le pfr de revoir ce qui est
dans pfr 3 ce qui est sûr c'est que oui
on comprend bien que vu la gravité de la
crise il a besoin d'avoir des
réajustements
ce que nous regrettons c'est qu'à chaque
fois que nous avons fait des
propositions j'avais fait une liste des
22 propositions que nous avions mis sur
la table pour le plfr un gouvernement
avait dit non puis les a reprises pour
le plfr deux bons d'un côté ça arrive ça
fait partie de la vie politique mais il
ya des choses qui aurait dû être fait
plus vite je maintiens je maintiens que
quand on a une économie qui fonctionne
pour sa création de richesses à 60% pour
la consommation et que la consommation
et celle qui s'est le plus effondré de
tous les pays de l'union européenne
de tous les pays des 27 pays le
gouvernement devrait mettre sa sous ses
yeux et se dire c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut agir
pour l'instant il ne le fait pas alors
est ce que l'on veut est-ce que
l'envolée du déficit français vous
inquiète
121 % du pib on était à 98,9 en 2019
on a l'impression que la france depuis
n'arrive pas à maîtriser ses finances
publiques
oui parce que
à mon avis on le prend toujours par le
biais on se pose pas la question de la
création de valeur ajoutée
je le regrette je le dis aujourd'hui
mais je l'avais dit à 10 ans à la sortie
de la crise de 2008 dans un livre donc
je pense que si on a un modèle social
qui fonctionne bien quand on a une
croissance économique autour de 2,2 2,5
pour cent quand on est en dessous ça
s'enraye parce que on n'a pas
suffisamment de recettes pour couvrir
les dépenses que nous devons avoir et
qui sont notre dans le fond c'est notre
modèle social et notre patrimoine fait
partie de notre adn notre culture donc
pour le préserver on a sept mois je suis
fondamentalement anti décroissance mais
on a sept câble cette nécessité de vous
produire la valeur ajoutée produire la
valeur ajoutée ça veut pas dire détruire
l'environnement
quand vous rénover des logements c'est
le plan que nous avons avec la prime
climat que nous avons proposé que nous
avions déjà proposé à deux mois qu'on a
un petit peu amendé au gré de la crise
quand vous rénovez votre logement vous
avez une baisse de votre facture
énergétique
vous avez une diminution du co2 et vous
fait travailler le bâtiment quand vous
arrivez à conjuguer tout ça c'est
gagnant gagnant planque l'économie pour
l'environnement et pour le social c'est
cette alchimie là qu'il faut arriver à
créer
moi je ne comprends pas que le
gouvernement n'ait pas envie d'être la
locomotive de sa vie comme locaux quand
le plan de relance de l'économie ça doit
être une relance verte pour vous mais ça
on fait c'est une relance verte c'est
une relance économique c'est une relance
sociale
vous avez les trois à la fois on va
parler du social mais quand même quand
vous voyagez parce que quand même ce cas
ce qu'a montré ce confinement c'est que
certes les émissions de co2 ont baissé
mais elles ont pas du tout baissé à
hauteur de ce qu'elle aurait dû au fait
du fait de l'acte du recul de l'activité
économique pourquoi parce que le gros du
gros de ses émissions de co2 c'est le
logement
ce sont les 7 millions de passoires
thermiques si vous ouvrez votre
radiateur votre chauffage et que tout
part à l'extérieur vous dégagez du co2
vous êtes mal chauffés et vous payez
cher donc là là dessus il ya vraiment
mais ça paraît du bon sens et vous allez
me dire mais pourquoi ça s'est pas fait
et bien je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
à la place du gouvernement je n'y suis
pas mais à la place du gouvernement ce
que je ferai c est cette locomotive avec
cette prime climat mais quand vous voyez
ces chiffres ce déficit supérieur à 11%
du pays
cette dette supérieur à 120% est ce qu'à
un moment il ne va pas falloir faire des
économies drastiques et ou pour vous
alors ce qui est sûr c'est que le
gouvernement fait peser 100% de toutes
ces dépenses sur la dette donc la
première question qui se pose c'est est
ce qu'il est sûr d'avoir bien sécuriser
l'approvisionnement en euros vous avez
des doutes
ben c'est pas que j'ai des doutes mais
je sais que la cause par exemple il ya
eu une ou deux journées où elle a peut
être en mesure d'emprunter de trouver
des prêteurs sur les marchés financiers
donc cette question là elle est
essentielle et ça ça doit se passer dans
un dialogue avec l'union européenne pour
la bce je fais vraiment un peu vraiment
jobs est le fait vraiment bien donc là
dessus on a cette sécurité
mais ça n'empêche pas de se poser la
question dont je ici même je crois ou
sur ce plateau ou en tout cas peut-être
par visio je sais plus parce que nous
faire perdre la mémoire
j'avais dit qu'il fallait qu'on se mette
autour de la table et qu'on dise comment
on finance la crise
ça peut pas être à 100% sur la dette ce
n'est pas vrai le gouvernement fait
l'autruche là dessus mais ce n'est pas
possible
sur la question du chômage la question
de l'emploi aussi patrice oui alors on
voit que l'on voit que le chômage
s'envole on voit qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui rit qui
pourrait être contrainte de licencier
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il ya une formule
intermédiaire parce que pour certaines
certaine il ya probablement à moyen
terme un peu de visibilité économique
comment est ce que l'état peut
accompagner ces entreprises pour pour
éviter cette casse sociale là il ya
plusieurs je pense qu'il faut le faire
de manière chirurgicale secteur par
secteur
aujourd'hui président la république va
annoncer un plan aéronautique jeu parce
qu'il y aura dedans on va parler de
l'aéronautique d'accord voilà
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'aéronautique on sait très bien que
tant que le trafic aérien ne reprend pas
et pour l'instant il reprend pas
vous ne pouvez pas avoir de commandes
pour autant ça veut pas dire que dans un
an
six mois il ne va pas reprendre ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on n'a pas une vraie
valeur ajoutée notamment sur l'avion
vers donc là-dessus doit y avoir un
accompagnement de l'état
mais ça doit être fait de manière
extrêmement chirurgicale quand la
consommation ne reprend pas vous avez
des restaurants ils vous disent mardi
dernier à l' ouverture ça a repris
depuis pour certains c'est un peu calme
là dessus il faut aussi qu'on se pose la
question de cette question de la
consommation c'est pas la même chose que
sur le trafic à ces dispositifs de
soutien à l'emploi et notamment le
chômage partiel est ce qu'il faut
poursuivre ce dispositif comme c'est
envisagé
quitte à ce que ça coûte aux finances
publiques de toute façon ça coûte soit
via la case chômage soit via la case
chômage ou en activité partielle
donc il vaut mieux privilégier
l'activité partielle et je pense qu'il
faut le faire secteur par secteur
on va parler de l'aéronautique vous avez
publié notamment une tribune dans le
journal du dimanche avec carole delga la
présidente de la région occitanie vous
le disiez le plan de soutien à la
filière sera présenté ce matin on parle
d'un plan d'un montant de 10 milliards
d'euros
alors il ya certaines mesures qui sont
attendus comme un dispositif de chômage
partiel de longue durée au moins jusqu'à
la fin de l'année pour la filière des
aides notamment aux pme et aux tpe sous
traitantes
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous de
ce plan moi j'en attends deux choses la
première c'est que on encaisse le choc
pendant 18 mois pendant que le trafic
aérien ne reprend pas et la deuxième
chose que j'en attends c'est que on se
positionne pour que l'europe soit le
leader mondial de l'avion vers c'est à
dire qu'on peut pas il faut qu'on
saisisse l'occasion de cette crise pour
investir sur l'avion vers vous avez
l'a321 qui est créé par airbus qui
dégage 30% de moins de co2 que les
générations précédentes
donc ça veut dire que la chaîne pour
construire cet avion
l'investissement pour cette chaîne doit
être lancée même si on est dans une
phase un petit peu compliqué on sait
très bien que c'est pas les chinois je
crois pas à nicomaque 10 boeing qui vont
se positionner sur ces segments l'a donc
nous ce que nous voulons c'est que
l'europe la france puisse être le leader
de l'avion vers est ce que ça peut
passer par exemple
des primes à la casse justement pour
sortir les avions qui sont aujourd'hui
les plus les plus polluants ça peut
passer vous savez l'état a mis 7
milliards pour air france 4 et trois
milliards via à la fois des fonds
propres et via des prêts donc il a quand
même un peu son mot à dire et j'espère
qu'il donne son mot que c'est pas juste
un chèque en blanc
donc là dessus il doit dire air france
vous devez en profiter pour refaire des
commandes notamment notamment pardon
d'avions plus propres plus verts gèrent
france de diminuer de moitié ses
émissions de co2 d'ici 2030 oui oui non
mais de toute façon c'est à ça doit être
un pacte donnant donnant ça peut pas
être l'argent public ne peut jamais être
un chèque en blanc ni un chèque gratuit
ça n'existe pas en tout cas de mon point
de vue du coup dans cette lignée la
france qui envisage de fermer les lignes
intérieures notamment les lignes qui
serait accessible en tgv à environ 2h30
est ce que pour vous mais ça on l'avait
demandé une solution là en terme
d'aménagement du territoire est ce que
vous ne craignez pas d'enclavé certains
territoires
mais disons qu'il faut quand même être
réaliste nous nous avions dit que quand
il ya une ligne lgv c'est pas forcément
la peine de prendre l'avion
bon ça c'était un premier point puis
deuxièmement si vous prenez toulouse où
c'est quand même la quatrième métropole
de france qui n'est pas accessible aux
lgv c'est vous savez c'est un feuilleton
cette lgv qui pour l'instant n'en voit
pas trop la fin il faut quand même
maintenir des lignes intérieures sinon
vous enclavées je pense que ce sera
aussi une opportunité pour le
gouvernement de se positionner vraiment
fermement sur la lgv mais ça c'est une
réflexion d'ensemble
voilà encore une fois je pense que sur
le plan aéronautique il ya plusieurs
sujets il ya nous on a chiffré
l'activité partielle mois par mois c'est
ce qu'on avait mis avec carole delga
dans la tribune dans les autres deux
autres sujets il ya ce qu'on appelle
l'organisation de la supply chain un
avion c'est un million pièce est le
modèle qui a été construit par f qui a
été inventé par la filière pour
construire ses avions
c'est d'avoir une tête de pont et puis
après chacun peut mettre son agilité au
service de la construction de cet avion
cette supplique chaîne aujourd'hui que
dans l'entreprise je crois oui
donc il va y avoir des regroupements des
regroupements d'entreprises aujourd'hui
le secteur aéronautique et le fait
partie comme un secteur stratégique
il n'est pas sécurisé en termes
d'investissements étrangers
la pharmacie si vous êtes un
investisseur chinois voulaient racheter
une entreprise pharmaceutique vous êtes
obligé de demander l'autorisation à
bercy ça fait partie du décret qui
existent pour l'aéronautique
rien de tout cela n'existe début avril
nous avons déposé une proposition de loi
en disant pendant la période d'état
d'urgence sanitaire on étend à tous les
secteurs ce dispositif de sécurité qui
existent c'est quand même pas la mer à
boire
via le gouvernement pour l'instant ne
bouge pas alors même que l'union
européenne a appelé l'ensemble des états
à protéger le capital de leur entreprise
c'est quand même incroyable ce point là
donc j'espère que dans le plan et les
annonces du président de la république
il y aura le fait qu'on ait tant ce
décret à tous les secteurs notamment à
l'aéronautique pour éviter que des
pépites de notre territoire se fasse
soit enfin dans le fond des proies
faciles pour des investisseurs qui
chinois qui est sûrs qu'ils écopent
comment comment expliquez vous qu'on
vous ait pas répondu justement sur ce
point là pourrait bien il faudrait que
vous posez la question à bruno le maire
je vous suggère de l'inviter lui poser
la question c'est incompréhensible
personne ne le comprend à chaque fois
que même jeu l'évoquent avec des
entreprises du territoire de
l'aéronautique personne ne comprend pas
les mots sur ce qui se passe au
parlement
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat qui
vont créer leur commission d' enquête
sur cette gestion
ducobu 19 et le gouvernement qui
envisage de créer la sienne pour avoir
un regard je cite indépendant sur ce
qu'il s'est passé qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
ah mais je suis scandalisée je sais que
le président larcher vraiment monté au
créneau je suis scandalisé j'entendais
la secrétaire d'état qui disent il faut
faire un retour d'expérience
enfin elle peut faire son retour
d'expérience tout seul puis j'espère
qu'elle sera plus bavarde et plus
précises lorsqu'elle répondre à la
commission d' enquête du gouvernement
que ce cas là était lorsqu'elle a
répondu aux parlementaires pendant les
deux mois de cette crise parce que
franchement c'était je trouve que
c'était pas du tout à la hauteur donc le
parlement est souverain
le parlement mènera une commission
denquête vous le savez mais je me
permets de le rappeler quand on témoigne
on le fait sous serment et il ya
effectivement des poursuites pénales qui
peuvent être engagées si on découvre que
vous avez menti
les rapporteurs peuvent faire des
saisies sur pièces et sur place
moi je les invite à aller saisir par
exemple sur les masques l'ensemble des
bons de commande les dates de commandes
les réceptions de saisir aussi tous les
contrôles qui ont été faits sur les
masques nous avons reçu pour savoir s'il
était bien conforme en tout cas ces cinq
j'attendais commission denquête et
j'espère etc ce sont les deux seuls qui
permettront d'avoir un éclairage
je crains que celle du gouvernement soit
peut-être une réécriture de l'histoire
je n'en sais rien enfin c'est du jamais
vu
une administration peut parfaitement
faire son retour d'expérience pour voir
quels sont les processus qui ont
fonctionné ou pas il n'y a pas besoin de
faire une troisième commission d'
enquête parallèle et de vouloir empiéter
sur les droits souverains du parlement
un mot rapidement sur les municipales
peut-être dans votre région notamment
cette commune de moissac dans votre
région qui risque de basculer au
rassemblement national comment vous
l'expliquez d'abord je soutiens estelle
hemmami qui porte donc à deux listes qui
sont en présence pour le second tour qui
porte le front républicain je pense
qu'il faut l'appeler comme ça mais enfin
qui portent de vraies valeurs pour
moissac qui a une grande histoire que ce
soit vous connaissez tous le chasselas
de moissac
en tout cas c'est un territoire
d'humanité je rappelle que moissac et
ville des justes qui a eu pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale une très riche
histoire et je pense que c'est ça qui
doit gagner j'aimerais que ce soit cette
boussole là qu'ils puissent
inspiré les électeurs et les électrices
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin merci patrice